this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist
we have all been physically ill before
we have all felt the strange deviant
nausea body aches fatigue and so on be
it from viral or bacterial infections or
otherwise perhaps we might have or
continue to experience the distress of a
genetic condition that impairs the
function of our heart lungs or other
parts of the body
in all of these cases the body functions
and is experienced differently compared
to what is otherwise understood to be
its normal condition
likewise in the case of mental illness
the mind functions differently compared
to what is understood to be its normal
condition more specifically the normal
conscious experience of the mind's
normal condition but what exactly does
this mean to experience an illness of
the mind what is the right normal
experience and how do we define and know
it
generally speaking psychological
disorders are defined as patterns of
thought feelings or behaviors that are
deviant from the cultural
classifications of normality distressful
and dysfunctional to living in society
or the world more broadly
beyond this however psychological
disorders can be fairly ambiguous and we
as a species are largely still at the
ground floor of our understanding
psychological disorders are both
extremely common and rarely extreme at
least in the sort of cases in which we
will be discussing here in a moment we
are generally all familiar with the more
common types or mid-level forms like
depression anxiety obsessive-compulsive
disorder bipolar disorder and so on
perhaps we are familiar firsthand
however there are types and forms of
conditions further out on the periphery
that can sound as if they are made up
like they are out of a psychological
thriller film
but these psychological thrillers are
the real lives of real people
and so this topic warrants delicate
handling and compassionate deliberation
there is a history of stigma
misunderstanding and poor treatment
associated with mental illness only
around the 18th and 19th centuries did
we even realize that mental disorders
could and likely were about a sickness
of the mind and we still have a long way
to go in terms of comprehensively
understanding what exactly a sickness of
the mind really is and means
failed by the seemingly invisible cloak
of consciousness an impenetrable subject
where nothing other than the subject
itself can know what the experience is
like disorders of consciousness of
mental experience are acts in the magic
show of the human mind that we still do
not fully comprehend
here are five particularly unusual and
unnerving psychological disorders that
truly showcase the mystifying nature of
the human mind
1. alien hand syndrome
alien hand syndrome is a condition in
which an individual's hand takes on a
life of its own the hand does not merely
involuntarily move at random but rather
the hand actually acts as if it has its
own conscious will a distinct separate
mind with intentions and desires
individuals with this condition can find
their hand carrying out goal-oriented
tasks and activities without intending
it or wanting to the hand might take
objects out of drawers unzipper a jacket
clothes or open windows and so on even
more strangely the hand is sometimes
known to do the opposite of what the
individual intentionally wants or just
did with their other hand for instance
the alien hand may open the same window
that the individual just intentionally
closed
the condition is understood to often be
caused by trauma stroke or a tumor
sometimes associated with cancer
aneurysms or brain surgeries there is no
known cure for the condition however and
it is still not fully understood
2.
derealization
derealization is a condition in which an
individual feels as though their
surroundings are unreal distant and or
distorted
people and objects seem to lose their
reality and the world can feel as though
it has been withdrawn or faded like it
is placed behind a pane of opaque
existential glass
temporary acute derealization is
experienced by a huge number of people
with up to 75 percent of the population
experiencing it at least a few times
throughout their life
however individuals can experience
chronic intensity realization in which
long extreme and frequent episodes occur
derealization is often experienced with
a similar condition known as
depersonalization which involves the
feeling of being disconnected from one's
own self the body mental processes or
both in the combined case the individual
experiences an ineffable detachment from
everything an awareness of being
something somewhere with no sense of an
anchor of reality to anything
the more chronic extreme form is
somewhat rare and is typically
indicative of several other
psychological disorders or medical
conditions often with severe trauma or
stress at the core
three disassociative identity disorder
disassociative identity disorder is a
condition in which an individual has
experiences and acts out two or more
distinct identities each with their own
differing personalities their own
memories and sense of the past their own
tastes and preferences and their own way
of determining the outward behavior of
the individual the disorder affects
between .01 and 1.5 percent of the
population although genetic and
biological factors are often believed to
play a role most typically cases stem
from some form of trauma with 90 plus
percent of cases involving childhood
abuse neglect or intensely distressing
events the condition is believed to
arise as a coping mechanism in an
attempt to deal with the traumatic
experience or memory the conscious mind
attempts to repress and contort itself
away from reality and in some part of
the process it appears to fragment or
split itself off into a different sense
of self or group of selves
although there are several ways of
treating this disorder currently there
are no formal universal treatments and
some that are used are even considered
controversial
four
cap grass syndrome
capgras syndrome involves the sudden and
false belief that someone or something
most often a close friend romantic
partner or family member sometimes
multiple has been replaced with an
imposter a sort of duplicate or clone
the belief is so real that no form of
reasoning explanation or proof can
change the affected individual's mind
sometimes the case can be so extreme the
individual becomes distant or even
violent with the loved one with whom
they believe has been replaced this
syndrome is understood to be primarily
caused by brain damage schizophrenia
alzheimer's dementia epilepsy tumors or
parkinson's disease however since it is
quite rare it's fairly hard to study and
a strong understanding is still mostly
unfounded
five codard syndrome collard syndrome is
a condition in which an individual
believes that they are dead dying or
simply do not exist it can also
sometimes involve the belief that parts
of one's body are missing
as a consequence of this individuals
have been known to exhibit self-neglect
or self-harm because since in their mind
they are dead what's the point
even more strange individuals with this
condition have also been reported
literally admitting themselves to a
morgue
coddard syndrome is fairly rare and hard
to study and so the causes are not fully
known many of the known cases involve
individuals who also suffer from
conditions like depression anxiety
schizophrenia substance abuse or some
sort of brain damage often from a stroke
tumor blood clot brain toxins or head
injury
exactly how why and what way this
response occurs though is still largely
unknown
arguably on some level we are all
familiar with the strange dissonance and
disorder of being in the general sense
men are so necessarily mad that not to
be mad would amount to another form of
madness wrote blaise pascal
for some people though this is not a low
hum in the background or underneath
reality it is reality it is a battle of
realities between what they experience
and what others experience and
collectively define as normal but what
does the psychologically disordered mind
suggest about the so-called stable one
about the self about our perception what
does it suggest about how fragile
reality is and how powerful and
mysterious human psychology is
the problem of course is knowing what is
and isn't real in a mind that prohibits
exit from one's own and entry into any
others while trying to define normalcy
in a universe that knows of no such
thing
this video was sponsored by blinkist
one particularly interesting book on the
subject of mental illness is madness and
civilization by the prominent 20th
century philosopher michelle vucco this
work explores the history and
development of mental illness in the
western world more specifically the
often troubling and misguided social and
medical perception and treatment of the
mentally ill with this video sponsor
blinkist you can learn from this book
along with many other books on similar
subjects like a first-rate madness by
nasirigami anatomy of an epidemic by
robert whittaker as well as thousands of
other books on different subjects each
in less than 15 minutes blinkist works
by condensing over 5000 nonfiction books
from 27 different categories into around
15 minute summaries streamlining and
providing each book's key takeaways and
important insights perhaps you are
interested in learning more from madness
and civilization about how facilities
were set up for the mentally ill during
the middle ages how treatments and
understandings of the mentally ill has
evolved from outcasts to medical
patients and so on but perhaps you don't
necessarily want to invest the 10 hours
required into reading the full version
at least not right away blinkist solves
this problem by allowing you to explore
and discover meaningful insights from
books like this in a fraction of the
time all blinkist summaries can be read
or listened to and can be accessed even
while you're offline additionally
blinkist has summaries of popular
podcasts as well as complete audiobooks
allowing you to delve even further into
books and topics once you've discovered
that you're interested through their
blanks use the link in the description
and you'll receive one free week of
unlimited access as well as 25 off a
premium membership the free 7-day trial
can be canceled at any time within the
trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you